now then let's get to the very latest
stop on brexit on de negotiation so I'm
joined now by the former Chancellor of
the Exchequer Philip Hammond who lost
the conservative with after voting
against the government to try to stop a
No Deal brexit very good evening tea
miss agreement now as you well know and
I'm sure you've read it all the
withdrawal agreement contains nearly 600
pages you voted for it three times while
you're in Teresa Mays cabinet if Boris
Johnson gets a deal it's not going to
look very different from that still you
voted for could you vote for Boris
Johnson's first she's not gonna look
very different from the one he resigned
over indeed but could you vote yes I
could it's not impossible that I would
support the deal but it's not just about
the withdrawal agreement we need to
understand the overall context what the
future relationship is going to look
like because there is no point taking us
out now in a way that means Great
Britain 98 percent of the UK's
population simply ends up at a No Deal
hardly round at the end of next year
what we know I think we know that this
package this deal is going to propose a
backstop for Northern Ireland so
Northern Ireland's future will be clear
we know what's going to happen there but
for the ninety-eight percent of us who
live and work in the rest of the UK
we're dependent on the negotiation of a
future relationship and if the
government is not prepared to make
commitments now as to what that
relationship is going to look like then
we could be heading for what is
effectively a No Deal brexit for the
great majority of British people well
let's just be clear Linda clearly people
because there's an awful lot of
complication here about what will be
voted on or could be a voted on there's
a political declaration alongside
withdrawal days right in which that kind
of questions I feel under Teresa may
talked about very close to line but
almost a level playing field now you
think Boris Johnson might change that
well we know that he has said that he
wants to take out some of the key
elements of that political declaration
and the price we will pay for taking out
those commitments on level playing
fields a fair playing field on which to
trade
is that the European Union will withdraw
their commitment to tariff free trade
between Britain and the European Union
and that means that we could be heading
to WTO terms trade arrangements for 98
percent of the UK at the end of 2020 and
that for me is a No Deal it may have
lipstick on it but it's still no deal
and this brings in the politics of it
all you referred to earlier on Boris
Johnson voting against withdrawal
agreement so the bones of which he
probably going to propose to Parliament
at at some point now this political
declaration it is thought that the
changes that mr. Johnson and others are
proposing are to entice the European
research group and also gave treasom a
so much trouble if that's the kind of
deal our so-called Canada - deal that's
the kind of deal they want yes that's
right they want a very distant
arrangement with the European Union that
will have a straighting essentially on
WTO terms and they want that because
they regard the most important priority
as being doing new trade deals with the
rest of the world so they would give up
our existing trade with Europe on which
our jobs and our businesses are built in
order to try to negotiate new trade
deals with countries large I told by
President Trump this is going to be a
pretty quick trade deal with the United
States and it will be quote-unquote a
beautiful one yeah but unfortunately for
President Trump he doesn't control us
trade deals it's the Congress that
controls them and we've had a very
different message from the Congress so
if we want a trade deal with the United
States it's very clear that we're going
to have to give access to US
agricultural products including chlorine
a chlorine wash chicken and hormone fed
beef that will be the first ask in a US
trade deal but the important point here
is not how difficult these trade deals
will be to negotiate or how unacceptable
to the British people it's this all the
analysis shows that even if we get all
these third country trade deals it will
only add a tiny tiny amount to our GDP
but we will lose a huge chunk of our GDP
if we voluntarily
give up access to the European market in
order to do those okay we've got your
analysis in full now and I want to bring
you back then to how that affects your
voting intention if the political
declaration looks like as you have
described you will vote against the deal
yes that's right or indeed if we don't
see a political declaration at all on
Saturday and I think it's perfectly
possible that all we will see is a
withdrawal agreement in some form
without the political declaration until
we understand the full package we can't
I think vote to support it and that's
not just because of the future of Great
Britain but also because we can't
understand what the Northern Ireland
backstop will mean for Northern Ireland
until we know where Great Britain is
going to be for example if Britain has a
tariff free trade deal with the European
Union then Goods flowing between Britain
and Northern Ireland will flow freely
and the Northern Ireland backstop will
not really affect life in Northern
Ireland but if we don't have a tariff
free deal with the European Union then
goods made in the UK in the rest of the
UK or agricultural products welsh lamb
for example will be subject to tariffs
payable when they move between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland that'll be
the hardest of hard customs borders in
the Irish Sea and that would be
unacceptable ok so in a vote if you
don't see a political declaration or if
it's radically altered you're voting
against it now you're the most senior
figure in the so-called expel EES these
21 conservatives who have the whip
withdrawn from them do you speak for
them all or the majority of them would
they also act like you obviously we're
all individuals people will make their
own decisions I think everybody wants to
support a deal but it has to be a proper
deol a real deal if all we're doing here
is making a deal for Northern Ireland
and papering over the fact that that
will leave Great Britain heading for a
very hard break sit at the end of next
year I don't think too many of my
colleagues will be prepared to
that could you pushing it because
numbers in numbers will be very
important you know do you pee then and
the ERG vote for government your folks
are going to be be critical knows
they're the government maybe one of you
the government needs not only the ERG
and the DUP it needs every single one of
the former conservatives who have had
the whip withdrawn to vote with it and
and therefore the government needs to
give us some very strong reassurances
about what the future relationship will
look like what's in the political
declaration it will need to tell us
whether it is going to abide by the
commitment that Teresa may made to
Parliament that Parliament would have
oversight of the negotiating mandate and
the progress of the negotiations during
that crucial second phase because if
Boris Johnson is planning to withdraw
all those commitments and hollow out the
political declaration then I think we
will know then that what this package is
envisaging is Britain Great Britain
heading for a hard no deal exit at the
end of 2020 and that's not accepted as
Miss Johnson also have to offer you the
conservative whip back look again
different members of the group will have
different views about how transactional
they want to be about this for myself I
am going to vote on the the package and
on any future legislation on the basis
of whether I believe it's in the best
interest of the country of course I'd
like to get the whip back but that is
not going to I'm not going to compile of
the transaction if I'm absolute you're
not going to be bought what about other
votes that might show who might not
happen on Saturday you certainly will
come at some point a general election do
you vote for a general election at this
point no I think we've got to sort this
out first because a general election
won't resolve this issue indeed a
general election potentially is quite
dangerous because a party winning a
general election governing with a
majority might have only 35% or even
less of the popular vote and the idea
that an issue which has been initially
decided by a referendum can be finally
disposed of by a general election to me
is very very problematic let me put that
right back at you then know what about
the some thoughts that a deal may be
amended and get voted through if it has
a confirmatory referendum attached is
that something well that is an idea that
the opposition parties in particular are
very attached to and one or two
conservatives my personal position has
always been that I don't believe a
referendum is going to be the best way
to resolve this we have because the
referendum has a binary outcome and at
the end of a referendum whether it's
50/50 or 60/40 you have a huge chunk of
the population feeling that their
position has been disregarded and
totaled that they're totally crushed the
only way for us to go forward as a
country is to find a middle ground a
compromise which will not satisfy the
hardline er jeers and will not satisfy
the hardline remainders but will allow
most people to say okay look I got some
of what I wanted if I was a remainer I
got at least a close trading partnership
with the EU even though we've left the
European Union and if I'm a lever I can
say we'll look we're closer than I want
it to be to the EU in trade terms but at
least we've left the Union we're out of
the political structures we're not a
member any longer but we're not paying
for it any longer the last points I mean
we haven't discussed the effect
potentially on Scotland if this
withdrawal agreement if it does get
voted through and the provisions as we
understand them applying to Northern
Ireland their sense that the Scots are
gonna say Nicholas turds it's gonna say
well well we want that special status
and perhaps independence is the way to
access it well I think there is a very
real threat to the Union if we go down
that route because in Scotland there
will be two arguments first of all there
will be a sense of grievance about the
fact that Northern Ireland has been able
to remain very close effectively in the
single market and the customs union
because that's what this proposal is
however you dress it up
and there will also be a very strong
sense of grievance that Scotland which
voted to remain has been forced out of
the European Union
so that's fertile territory for people
who want to break up the United Kingdom
which again I believe is a very very bad
outcome not just for the United Kingdom
for the people of Scotland lastly mr.
Hammond if and when a general election
comes with or without the whip is your
intention to stand again in your seat
that is my plan
to stand in runnymede and Weybridge if I
can stand as a conservative I will do if
the Conservative Party doesn't allow
that I will stand as an independent
conservative and continue to espouse the
kind of conservatism that I believe is
what made our party is successful as it
has been over hundreds and if you stand
as an independent if you had any
conversations because of course you have
been talking to them about the bear now
the rest of any conversations with the
Liberal Democrats and the Labour Party
about who might oppose you I haven't I'm
not going to enter into those kind of
discussions while I'm still a member of
the Conservative Party and indeed
subject to the process of Appeal which
the Conservative Party has I hope that
the whip will be restored to me and that
the Conservative Party will decide to
remain a broad Church where people of
very different opinions can work
together and can happily coexist within
the same party that's what we've always
been and that's what we need to be in
the future if we are going to be a
successful political party ok mr. hammer
thank you very much very good to see you